[Music]
hey guys I'm Liana Galera from
Entertainment Tonight and I am joined on
the outlander set by two amazing people
we've got Sophie Skelton and Richard
Rankin thank you so much for having me
and I'm so excited we're gonna be
getting so much more of you guys in
season 3 we got little baby snippets in
season 2 but what has it been like for
both of you guys just entering outlander
world it's been because we've always
known that we were gonna have quite a
gradual introduction in this story and
then we knew there were roughly what was
going to be involved in season 3 and
it's like we've been just slightly
segregated from the rest in the past
they're moving back in the 18th century
warm in the sixties interior and they're
sludging through the mud how fun has it
been for you guys to kind of walk around
in those sixties clothes are you jealous
of of Katrina's corsets a little until
you hear stories in the closet when she
can't breathe or eat you kind of happy
in your big baggy sixties Joey just
reported in we've had a pretty good hmm
well what can you guys tease about what
fans can expect in season 3 about
Landers a lot more of the sort of
Rihanna Roger relationship development
massive development you guys had
instantaneous chemistry I feel like we
saw that spark right away what's it been
like for you guys to find that chemistry
off-screen you try to have a
conversation with this one important you
know we get one together on the same
page we've spent a lot together we chat
a lot about the carats of a chat la but
the relationship and the development the
relationship which I think it's really
helpful 9 teams that attend Sophie
doesn't agree with what I've got to see
it but she license do you see a lot more
of brand modular kind of their
relationship coming together but then an
equal amount means sort of torn apart as
well so even with some scenes they sort
of read one way but then we've talked
about it and played it out and actually
some of the scenes have turned out quite
different than we both imagined I love
that well I had the pleasure of touring
your Boston home with Katrina
yes it's very blue it's his kind of work
it definitely worked and she was telling
me that she's been having so many
amazing scenes with you and really
tapping into her maternal instincts yeah
that's it been like shooting with
Katrina and really finding that motherly
bond onstage she's been really lovely
actually his last season obviously these
two strong women kind of clashed heads a
lot which you still see some of in this
season but you do also see that element
where is that really strong
mother-daughter bond which they kind of
haven't had really for the past 20 years
so it's nice to see them come together
and they kind of become friends as much
as mother and daughter which there's
some really lovely scenes in that in
that foster home well I'm so excited for
the fans to get to know you guys more
you're just so delightful thank you so
much for sitting down with me I really
appreciate it and thank you fans so much
for watching for all the latest news be
sure to follow Outlander on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
[Music]
you